[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hello and welcome to The Omen eSports
report for our last show of the series
it's a little bit sad to be honest with
you but we're still gonna have a pretty
good time um what's what's this okay
greetings from us a bear with me a
second dear mark currently sunning
myself in America I hope you have a
lovely time yet eh yeah yeah uh good
luck from Rachel slightly whirring
unbelievable not doing this show my on
my own worried about it
it's we're not going to leave you today
easy Rachel well let's take a look at
what we've got for you tonight
coming up on tonight's show we take a
look back at the months past action in
the eSports 60 our guests aiming skills
are put to the test in the headshot
challenge we'll be joined by a special
guest Jackie Martin Creek orcs and
Gregan
and a little bit of a heart attack until
you walk down those stairs there to be
honestly I thought Rachel just left me
on mind high and dry it was tempting
you're gonna leave me kind of a little
bit I mean I'm glad to have you here on
the show anyway GI I should we get
things going let's do it role titles
[Music]
[Applause]
time I need to kick off proceedings man
and as always we'll open with the
biggest headlines from the world of
eSports over the last month all in just
60 seconds you're ready mark I kind of
have to be at this point though you're
up first
okay season three begins in Apex legends
and brings with it a new legend crypto
rule is an industry that the oil yes
might be considering franchising for
that seat turn back the clock by picking
up a win at Dreamhack Masters melvoy all
three EU teams battled their way to the
quarterfinals of wealth
right and out seven yes seven new games
are on their way the facelift the
fan-favorite cash is revealed at ESL new
york san francisco shock beat vancouver
titans to win the o WL title
epic games kept everyone guessing at
sport like the gang Chapter two
and finally some sad news as splice
revealed to be shutting down as a brand
[Music]
well there we go
60 seconds we've got it done but it was
in a small compact volume just like just
to bring it to you easy easy
what was your favorite part the last
month I think it has to be all of the
announcements coming out from riot I
mean what kind of video game developer
just says oh he says so making by James
exciting right yes in all the different
genres there is something for everybody
it's absolutely ridiculous mine of
course was a peck season 3 I'm a huge
apex fan and I've been grinding my way
up the leaderboards and my ranks and you
know Krypto has been helped me out a
little bit but yeah a lot of fun a lot
of fun well one other thing I thought we
could take a look at is something I've
had put together called the month in
numbers Twitter edition this takes a
look at what were the best performing
games for viewership on Twitch in
September and 2019 versus 2018 here we
go then let's start off boy I look at
this massively down compared to 2018
yeah well the Warcraft is up
significantly in 2019 due to the release
of classics I know a lot of people have
been playing that obviously been playing
that GTA is up to to the amazing
emergence of role-playing and watched so
many twitch through that saw anything
well Bungie has completely disappeared
from the list 2019 yeah that's looking a
little bit scary pop diva overwatch csgo
I'm League of Legends all remain pretty
even across both ears no real surprise
there you know three of the biggest
eSports in the world they're keeping
that consist well last month saw the
omen challenge taking place here in
London where we had six pro players and
two amateurs going head-to-head in a 1v1
brawl on a custom map with a top prize
of 30,000 dollars on the line now the
event was absolutely insane we had some
incredible a are on display if you
didn't see it let's take a look what's a
place
we just get an even this idea is to be
wild
[Music]
so really super exciting
[Music]
so if we needed to be told simple is
really good at csgo
you're pretty nice knew that but how
good did that look oh it was amazing I
got one of the t-shirts that his name on
it which everyone was going for because
they were worn it the simple one no I'm
not surprised I mean how scared would
you be if you just when it's a game csgo
and saw simple yeah you're out there you
can we've got plenty more to show you
today so let's have a look and a
reminder of what's coming up on the show
still to come on the show check out the
straight virtuoso Jackie joins us on the
sofa it's team mark versus team geo in
the rocket League challenge we visit egx
to get the inside scoop on the latest
gaming releases and we're also joined by
the UK league of legends expert ox an
absolutely Ram show to finish up the
series tonight and the one thing you
aren't gonna want to miss is that final
rocket League showdown between myself
and mark to decide the overall winner
for the season don't forget we'll be
giving away the incredible prizes on
screen now to whoever guesses the
correct outcome of that match details on
screen right now on how to enter but
it's time now to introduce our wonderful
guest form that well maybe you will one
day along everybody looking forward to
the show yeah yeah it should be able to
get great today okay well we'll start
with you Jackie of course you've got
some beautiful glasses on there you very
much we have to just highlight very
quickly we don't know who Jackie is
let's take a quick look
they shall be a very brave soldier
bullfrogs look I recommend when should
be able to come in fairly throw fit this
is the one time they're not going to
live up to their later swipe me a cheeky
play for the smoke does push apply me no
surely not the butcher playful true
stroke I hope you've enjoyed the stream
though from me and from the tick master
himself we will see the legend Jackie
how are you mate you good I'm good it's
good to see you you know we've been away
for some time but I'm reunited near you
again alright we are in the same kind of
Oh No which is terrifying for a lot of
people it's a game
let's talk csgo though because obviously
well that's where you you know your
bread and butter is let's what you you
do best the current state of serious go
is very interesting because we've had a
lot of different winners to pop it up
recently we have right obviously New
York I was there covering the B stream
it's the fact that eg finally returned
to CS which is like one of the most
prestigious orgs in gaming as a whole
they pick up energy there were a team
that were on top absolutely demolishing
there just showing how good they could
be as a squad right they rebrand they
come in they don't drop single game
they're go on to win the event huge huge
story drink it drop it a single game any
game in any sports insane right you're
returning to like as a prank Mikey do
you work yeah and then they just go on
to Malmo everyone's thinking alright you
know are we into the height now are they
gonna be able to carry this on but no
all of a sudden that's where the changes
happen the new fan out across the swoop
in absolutely smash it everyone's hike
to see golden back it's crazy mark
things are looking absolutely
ridiculously competitive and of course
for a csgo fan which you know we all
have that little bit of a suit everybody
mazes roll around always have to turn on
the CS and see what's going down it's
just exciting times for the for the
audience and for spectators there's so
much coming especially with the Pro Tour
that's now coming into a fete which is
kinda like the next step for countless
tracks evolution I feel in a lot of the
ways the tournaments now have a linked
meaning across the board it's crazy it's
a great thing I love see us well one of
the interesting things going on in CS at
the moment if they're making changes to
how the economy works in the game why
don't you tell us a little bit about
that and maybe explain it to people who
maybe aren't so familiar with the game
okay well yeah we obviously we have the
economy change that came in a little
while ago now which basically may piss
arounds a little bit redundant in the
way they played before you would really
a big bang for your buck if you took
those pistols Jason Lake would have been
very happy but the difference is these
days where the economy's in a little bit
of a different state you get that
increased loss bonus there's more to
play for you can't really break
someone's economies as easily right
but once that came in there wasn't
really much discussion of is this gonna
be updated is this gonna be changed as
this gonna be based on feedback it just
kind of happened and it's been the same
since so now people are starting to talk
about the fact that is this just how
it's gonna be is there gonna be any
potential changes to that what are we
looking at here because obviously
changing the economy is that you
changing the entire heart the game I
mean the interesting thing for me is
yeah it's great for me because I lose
most of my early rounds as you would
expect I actually get to use an ache
ache ache as Liam and around CS which is
which is great fun but how do you think
it's going to affect the competitive
meta as we see new changes we have
definitely seen changes in the way the
games approached right because you can
buy more regularly completely basically
change as some of the maps in the way
they're played just because you can get
you know you can get those full buyers
out more it is sort of the question
though of has that increased pace of the
game and being able to just invest all
the time change CS in a way that you
know maybe isn't for the better that's
well we kind of sat now where it's it's
a discussion on that okay for the works
it's not just counter-strike Jackie of
course the no-name before you dabble in
many different titles one of them is
kind of one of the forefathers of
eSports and that is of course quake I
talked to us a little bit about some of
your quake quake you do it the ground
poppy of FP yeah it is the poppy it is
it is indeed and it's it's a great
feeling to work on it you know it's a
game with so much prestige and history
behind it with all the amazing things
that have come from quaking quakecon as
a whole and I now get to be a part of
that alongside zu who's a very
established member of the community
we've basically made a bit of a boy band
called jiu-jitsu T sounds like it works
you know it's been really fun we've
essentially done a good majority of
stage one of the quake Pro League it's
now coming up to Lucca which is the
first LAN finals for it so this is
really a chance for all of the players
to prove what has been proven over the
course the online season on LAN and have
some huge results as we slowly get
closer and closer towards QuakeCon 2020
well Marc and I already discussed the
new titles that right are going to bring
out but one of them is this project a
that's been announced that's gonna be
that shooter I know one of the many
they're tactical shooter and is really
looking like they're going after players
of CS and overwatch both of which you do
have experience in so where do you think
that may go with those player bases so
now this is an interest in 1g I've
fought really quite hard about this I've
been looking for a lot of the footage
that's come up you can see on the screen
here with obviously volcano being shown
kill feed that someone that has such a
huge impact on counter-strike there's a
whole with as we said with a cast remake
coming out even he played his part in
that Maps design there's still integral
to it over the course the years right
this is a game that he's basically
invested his life blood into tried to
make basically Counter Strike 2 in a way
they want to combat that but they also
want to try and bring people in from
other games like overwatch as you can
see on screen here with some of the
abilities that come out I feel like the
approach the game that they've taken off
of the back of seeing they are gonna
have a bye menu in it is that maybe they
want to try and give you heroes that
have different abilities you purchase
rather than buying utility like I'm
gonna smoke grenades and flashes I
instead have this smoke war that I can
throw out and that might be there sort
of gambit into that which it could be a
smart way to do it it's definitely a you
know a different twist on it but any
competition of counter-strike is good at
this point right you know give a summit
to to work against there was so much
obviously I think a lot of us were very
excited when it when it came out and
it's it's good to I would just check
with you guys obviously you're pretty
excited I'd imagine when that riot came
out went yo seven games what you
thinking I mean for me I like the
shooter was the most surprising morning
because everything else sort of fit into
the world of League of Legends which is
from Terra but the difference with this
should it is it's completely just
separate from that and that for me was
the biggest surprise I'm excited for it
and they fix the internet as well we've
sort out they borrowed it from Google
yes well maybe that's the most exciting
thing but so many things changing in CS
and these other games jackie thank you
so much well all of you guys at home
here's a reminder of what's coming up
still to come on tonight's show we see
who can aim under pressure in the
headshot challenge jackie analyzes an
iconic csgo clip in the
down we learn about the history of
modding in eSports and Martin Creek
joins us on the sofa time for the
headshot challenge now and it's a battle
of two fps experts as Jackie takes on
Martin to see if they can end the season
at the top of our leaderboard let's take
a look at what happened welcome back to
this month's headshot challenge where
we're going to set up two of our guests
to go head-to-head on a csgo aim map at
the same time I'm going to be asking
them this all that questions to try and
distract them and they have 60 seconds
to see who gets the high score
now we're going to be starting with
Jackie how are you feeling I'm good I'm
excited I'm ready yeah well I mean you
know you've worked in csgo you should be
feeling pretty ready the timer is going
to start when you get your first
headshot so off you go take it away all
right are you ready for your questions
take them to me bring them on tea or
coffee coffee frozen yogurt or ice cream
ice cream
League of Legends or dota dotI okay that
wasn't one of the options but final
access to Jedi or Sith is an important
step because I'm a G yeah I can tell by
your shirt thank you hard world of soft
world you've got just about 10 seconds
left over sure is on pub G or apex apex
and last one restaurant or take away
take away time's up
you happy with your school I could have
done better let's be honest you know I
feel about the dough to your question
for me off all right well it's time to
see our next competitor Martin so now
it's time to see how our second guest
Martin is gonna do now Martin I'm not
gonna tell you how Jackie did I'm gonna
tell you you're gonna have to try really
hard but there still is that chance to
get at the top of the leaderboard your
time starts after you get your first
headshot go pancakes or waffles waffles
apples or pears pears a bran popcorn or
Naturals popper Batman or Superman
Superman pac-man or Tetris Tetris let's
go put our music zoo or aquarium four
facts
boys or NSYNC and Singh so much passion
hotel or camping hotel night hour or
early riser you've got just under 10
second I doubt Coke or Pepsi coke smooth
or crunchy crunchy wet or dry dry time
is now time to see how our contestants
did it's time to find out what the
scores were boys are you ready
I don't which of you thinks are actually
gonna come higher than the other this
guy I mean even yourselves a countess
right guy all right that's what was my
strength well if you look behind it
you'll see the leaderboard so actually
Dan Gaskin I've been beaten by my
nobody's so you gonna top Jackie you're
there with 30 points you scroll down a
little bit there's a mark on set Hatcher
sitting there at fourth quite you know
we're still waiting for you to show up
and it's good you know here as well and
then at the end we have Rob sitting at
the bottom with 21 points actually kind
of happy but um is good job salt in the
wound you know he's there in a Mefford
shirt and SCO's beaten me second time
this year I'm happy thank asking came
above you oh forget about down okay well
now that we have found out those scores
we know who is one let's send it over to
past mark to take us through the
breakdown okay it's time for my favorite
part of the show and sadly for the last
time this series it is time for the
breakdown I've got one of my favorite
human beings in the world alongside me
this time is of course Jackie
counter-strike maestro himself and
you're gonna help us break down some
counter-strike not surprised hopefully
start we're going back to calve it's a
2018 I know we're bringing it back it's
all coming into flavor the Elite Series
is return mark and I'm very excited for
it let's have a look at this play there
because it's a bit of a buzzing one for
me I've always been excited about this
rotation
we dub it the mighty max rotation to our
big man himself but what we're gonna be
looking at here first is the placement
of where they've come out it is a bit of
a rush by they've gone in for
essentially they've had to invest
whatever they could try and scrape
through this round it's very important
in the overall terms of the game if they
win it they set themselves up to take it
the smokes they've gone down here at a
block off the entry over from jungle and
over from CT mark which is pivotal they
need to be able to block off that area
to try and give himself chance to get
the bomb down because the post plant is
walking out here that's the most
important play as soon as this bomb goes
down we're gonna be looking at glaive
who will start his absolute marathon
journey the whole way around out CT up
fruity spawn and back here Awards short
where he's gonna try and set himself up
for the area with a peek over and try
and defend the bomb when the CTS are
going in for the retake mark so we're
gonna watch this roll on a little bit
and see the play obviously develop
itself and things I'm looking too bad at
the moment is kind of evened up but this
is where things really start to turn
here you'll see a few players drop and
you'll find you know the situation you
don't want to be in if you're trying to
be in that past post plant position yeah
it gets a bit rough right devices left
on a scenario that is really really
unfavorable in terms of his odds of
winning the round but luckily his saving
grace in glaive is starting to make his
move over to ward shor ideally device
gets one frag here instead he falls and
now we're left with this scenario four
players alive all of them on fairly high
HP which is never a good position to be
in mark so and then we're gonna see this
huge play here this damage done is so
important to the result of this complete
play yes it is the post part they're
coming into full effect clay killed too
but also leaves them on low HP he goes
in low SK played it flawlessly one
player on the bomb one player holding
four that push upstairs he's still been
able to execute both for them and clutch
out the round purely because of him
having the advanced positioning that he
had with a post pump being onshore and
the fat time was so low they couldn't
come off the bomb they have to just
accept it so post plant position is
obviously what you were highlighting
here let's talk about what players at
home can do to add something like this
to their game you talked about the
rotation itself what can you say some
advice you can give to players at home
you always want to be thinking about
what you're doing with the bomb right
it's not a sort of mindset of going to a
site slap it down and do anything with
it it's not like delivering post you
don't want to just fling it in there
you've got to be really quite clever
about things mark plant your position
that sets you up to cover it Eva from
the round after you've got the bond
or if you're just going for cash think
about how you're gonna be able to keep
yourself safe to plant it and get away
with the extra money on to those eco
rounds it's all about the positioning
amazing so positioning is key of course
in count straight Jackie absolute
pleasure to have you break that
awareness let's take a look at what's
coming up on tonight's show here's what
still to come on tonight's show
friggin joins us to talk all things
rocket League we head it to the Excel
Convention Center to check out egx in
the finale of the rocket League
challenge team mark takes on team geo
and finally we look ahead of what to be
excited about in the month ahead
alright so much more to come on
tonight's show as we can see but now
it's time for our first feature which is
going to be on the origins of eSports
and interestingly we just talked about
counter-strike jockeying that's kind of
fits in nicely here it does right being
born from a mild all those years ago
coming into again it's so established
now crazy well you said the word itself
it is of course mods and modding let's
take a look at how it shaped eSports
wouldn't I even think when they think of
the big game developers valve software
Blizzard Riot Games do we think right
well these people made an eSports game
and they must have a handle on what you
sports games are like but if you look
the big games of the past all their
successes comes from mods
what's his modding mods or modifications
are custom elements added to a game by
the community these can range from a new
skin for a character all the way up to a
whole new way to play you look at a game
like League of Legends dota 2 heroes of
the storm these games all go back to
dota Defense of the Ancients which was a
mod it was a register map of Warcraft 3
games such as Warcraft 3 spawned
thousands of custom maps custom
characters and custom game modes all
driven by the community the original
dota was one of these game modes and
went through a number of iterations and
a number of creators before eventually
settling on Defense of the Ancients as
we know it when dota all-stars came
together it was a combination of all of
these different types of ideas that
people had around this this game mode
and piled it all into one big thing
which has been refined over the years
mods allow players to make the games
they otherwise didn't have the expertise
to create from scratch this freedom of
creativity allowed people to finally
play the exact type of games they were
looking for the type of game that didn't
yet exist on the mainstream market at
the time I was really interested in
Counter Terrorist forces that level of
sophistication in terms of the weaponry
in terms of the tactics I thought that
would make a great theme for it
our server was called like the cod of
dayz that it was that kind of just spawn
loot up and kill everyone else and go
hunting and that's where about where I
came for a because I saw that people
were spending you know about an hour
every night on the server they would
come in play for an hour and leave and I
saw that you know if you just want
compressed that sort of experience into
a game holder and then that well what's
made for perfect eSports because at
their core oaths were about communities
both were driven by passionate creators
and competitive player bases that strive
to improve themselves as well as their
game dota started as an idea a custom
idea which developed into a community
which then developed into a competitive
community which has now developed into
an industry I believe I'm the luckiest
man in gaming you know it's from someone
who had no experience in gaming you know
was essentially an out-of-work
photographer and designer and now I'm
creative director at a games company you
know and to be given that choice chances
is huge you know I I bless my lucky
stars every day whatever the future may
hold for eSports there's one thing you
can guarantee mods will still have a
part to play see obviously mods and the
effect that they've had on eSports I
think we can all agree we've got a lot
to thank mods for basically everything
but next up we need to introduce our
next guest and I'm looking at him
because you know I'm big fan of his and
of course it is Martin Creek if you
don't know who he is
well you should by now and if you don't
of course we'll just have a look at this
package
[Music]
got em people got him I bet you forgot
about Jim Carrey as my troubles trying
to find someone to put some bullets in
[Music]
welcome to the couch great to have you
here we just learned a little bit about
you firstly you know welcome as I say
let's talk about your career because we
were lucky enough to meet for the first
time a little bit earlier this year I
working a little bit of fortnight
together but tell us where it all
started
yeah right so you and I met when there
was a fortnight tournament for fortnight
casting it was my biggest event in my
casting career before that I was just
the streamer I started out on justin.tv
many many years ago we will remember
justin.tv right and then I went over to
twitch why because you were kind of
forced that way right which way you were
doing things like dressing up like the
mosque
his name is Pronk so classic that's
another story he's a good lad here's a
good luck clearly touched a nerve yeah
but yeah stream for a little bit got
partnered kept that going start playing
hearthstone play that professionally for
about two and a half years for SK gaming
and read reserve after that I wanted to
get into casting because I had like a
bunch of people that I just really
looked up to and yeah that's where you
are now
that's right now yeah so obviously we
sort of touched on fortnight a little
bit about it's also world of warcraft
you've been involved with but I think we
should continue down the path of
fortnight for a while because we had
somewhat of a er you know an event that
happened recently that kind of blew the
internet up it blew media up it blew
some people up to be honest with you
with the way that they reacted to the
game talk to us about you know fortnight
chapter 2 obviously the event that went
round there okay so first off when they
shut down the game for two days with the
black hole and everything I got a phone
call from my sister my nephew's were
going crazy we thought the game was over
I think we all had that slight worry did
tweeting being like oh my god epic
actually ended for tonight yeah but I
mean they probably wouldn't write but
they have a really good history of
making like really good events and like
the mech versus the monster and all the
fun stuff they're really good at that
and this is a whole new like revamp of
the game it's I wouldn't say it's
completely different but there's some
it's more balanced now I would say
there's no mix there's boats instead
they can shoot away like a little
missile there's fishing so it's kind of
turning into an MMO it's like Warcraft I
was gonna say a lot the competitive
community I think of reacted quite well
yeah new season because as you say it's
a little bit more balanced and there is
that kind of equality across fights etc
how have you found it playing wise you
felt the same way yeah I mean it's it's
in a much better state than it was a
couple of months ago um they took out a
lot of weapons now a lot of imbalance
stuff and the more you take out the more
you have to take in later I guess so I'm
a little bit worried about that but the
entire pro scene right now they're very
very happy with how the game is and yeah
we're just all holding our thumbs you
know well you're talking about MMOs how
it's becoming a little bit more like an
MMO and we did already mention that
you've been involved in World of
Warcraft quite a bit so tell us a little
bit about your journey and that cuz
you've done quite a lot with World of
Warcraft this yeah right
yes I'll race the world first by method
I'm sure we all know about that right
now Jackie does experienced it all but
yes I did that casted the classic launch
event and also the race to first azshara
kill me man here that did you hmm
didn't get the kill they did you know
this annoyed me so much because pretty
much every caster we've got a kill like
they get they got to cast a kill yeah I
only got to cast like recoils
like I got I got no kill and a funny
thing I was heading out of the of
detective Atia of the studios on my way
home as they were doing the last try of
Azshara and then all of a sudden I hear
like no no no you have to say you have
to say I run back like with my bag and
everything and they get to kill
everybody
and then I jump into my camera life I
see you were like a few seconds off of
having Matt oh yeah I was this close to
missing it and I was really worried of
that day that I wouldn't miss it because
I had a flight but you did have the last
laugh though because you know obviously
method did win that race so Jackie you
weren't aware if you weren't aware by
the way that Jackie was casting some of
the other teams who were trying to make
that well we saw him for missing out on
that you're Cossack it was a bit
underwhelming though by your own
admission yeah we it was mostly a
discussion about my chia pet that I had
grown was a lovely lady Charlotte grew
very well and I was surprised
unfortunately she did die at the end of
the stream but I think I used to not
enough sunlight but you know it happens
it happens someone go world walk off sir
it's kind of reacquainted onto the
eSports scene a little bit to be honest
with race the world first its kind of
carved a path out for it where do you
see that going in the next sort of six
months twelve twelve months okay so
obviously there's new rape tears coming
out soon so we'll probably see something
something by metha then maybe some other
places as well who knows but the thing
that interested interest there's me the
most weird bubble is classic right
because you can do so much with classic
you can do like all the new raids the
old new raids you can race for those but
they really they're really easy though
right but it's still gonna be fun but
dueling tournaments dealing to know
that's what you want to see yeah we
already see some of that buy tips outs
in method as well they they're
organizing right now like a very big
dueling tournament but there's a lot of
things you can do with World of Warcraft
laughs so yeah so obviously a lot to
look forward to in the future yeah all
sounds pretty exciting thank you so much
for you know telling us all about that
and hopefully it all goes pretty well in
the future but now it's time for the
second of tonight's features and if he
just I got a chance to visit eg eggs for
the first time ever and see what
everybody has been raving about and
catch up with a few familiar faces
for the first time in a few years ETX
has returned to London so we've come
along to see everything it has to offer
so many new games so many competitive
opportunities for players so let's go
take a look
our first opera GX is the omen stage
where I've found a familiar face what
have you been up to over the last couple
of days because such a price to run into
you but you've been pretty busy super
busy yeah I've been stationed in the
beautiful Holman stage behind us we've
been doing competitions tournaments
challenges giveaways and having a lot of
fun with it it's been a great time the
most important question how much
caffeine have you had over the course of
the few days so far I think you have to
invent a new unit of measurement to be
honest with you it's 1:00 on set is why
I've had of caffeine which is a lot so
maybe a company that you associate a
little bit more with the sort of games
that are happening behind me but you may
not know that they actually have a
really thriving eSports scene across we
have been they've been hosting
tournaments in Super Smash Brothers
splatoon and even a little bit of
overwatch I managed to find another
friendly face outside the omen stage my
favorite ever content creator how is
your day being today so far super tired
it started at like 4 o'clock in the
morning to get here and then yeah just
onstage all day have you had a chance to
look around anywhere else in the
convention yet no my life right now is
inside the omen booth but tomorrow in
the morning I'm gonna come have a look
around Riot Games had a big presence
with their newly announced card game
drew Tara the title is said in the same
world as League of Legends and looks to
be a fierce rival to hearthstone and
artifact
yeah on yeah one of the staples of eg
axe is the Capcom Pro Tour EU qualifiers
behind us we see two of the best players
fighting it out for the top 32 those
you make it into the top eight tomorrow
and earn points to go into the Capcom
Pro Tour the competition that ejects is
always very stacked it's an event that
gives you a lot of mileage if you come
far
the original finals and it'd be a native
Big Bird claiming the belt what's
special about egx
is not only the celebration of gaming
but also the strong sense of community
it inspires the community here is
literally the one thing that makes me
wanna come every time literally the
people everybody's understanding and
unaccepting especially it's like a
family and I genuinely have like built
friendships like long-term friendships
outside of the game through here
all in all it's been a great return to
London for egx
we've seen new games old games great
competitions and we can't wait to see
what it has in store for us next year
I actually ended up having a great time
at UGA
so Marg you were doing quite a lot of
work there what was it like working
there at the yeoman stage it was a lot
of fun it was genuinely a lot of fun we
had blindfolded second which I think was
one of the highlights of egx we had a
girl come up
it was winner stays on she took down to
tech and prose on her way to just win in
five straight rounds it was genuine like
I would have scenes they were scenes it
was all you know it was amazing oh my
god did any of you guys go yeah I was
there hello yeah there was a panel on
the Friday about getting a job in
eSports and we had Kirin from Excel
there someone belongs some of a British
eSports association that was really good
and then also just walking around the
booths just get better and better at
these events they're just getting bigger
more colorful trying to outdo each other
every time yes it was definitely amazing
for my first experience but moving on
from EDX it's time to talk to Dan but
before we do let's have a look at some
of his highlights finds water hose does
lad flag dragged straight on top of the
ball
[Music]
credit car back to the UK things looking
pretty exciting there you've had a
pretty storied career but the first
thing that we really have to talk about
is the things I've been going on with
the LEC teams at Worlds because that's
kind of shake in the world of eSports
right now yeah I mean coming in two
worlds obviously g2 had a great
performance at MSI one in the whole
thing there's a lot of expectations on
them for now that could made it very
close but the big surprise was splice
that a really close serious goodness
unicorns were loves to get through plans
and then for them to get not just to
group stage but also to the knockout
stage was obviously a massive
achievement for stealin our up against
SKT in the Korean teams once again are
looking like a dominant force so both
Korea and the LEC but three all three of
their teams through to the knockout
stage is not gonna like it's going to be
really exciting to see how it pans out a
lot of people have been talking about
how North America hasn't necessarily
been doing so well there's a lot of
things to say about that a lot of people
been having conversations about why by
the end of the day they fell flat on
their face all three teams not making it
through is a massive hit especially when
you have the likes of Coach game and go
and zero and six even Team Liquid who
everyone thought we're the strongest
team in na and had a good chance
who even beat IG who were the reigning
world champions amasai still ended up
flopping so North America definitely
struggling but if you European you're
doing great speaking of Europe let's
bring it even closer to home let's talk
about UK let's talk about the LVP
because you've been involved that
yourself what's it like to be part of
that community in the moment how is UK
legends
yes been great it's being grown quite a
bit I think a big factor is that fnatic
has now brought their Academy team for
like rising in we have excel go in the
LEC but they still have a team filled in
LVP and it brings up the competition
forever nails a lot of orbit when I
compete with that not just in terms of
strength on the rift but also in terms
of branding so a lot of tension put
there we recently had the live finals at
Air Twickenham
which is the sort of home turf for
excelent forcely they fell 3-1 tooth and
I rise in but it was a really close
series you talk about Excel they are the
team that you used to play for so how do
you think about their performance at the
moment do you think maybe one day
they'll have a spot in the world stage I
mean I think they definitely wanna
change things up for next year cuz I've
spoken a bit to some of the staff
members it's obviously been a big hit in
Tim's performance to come 10th place
back to back out I think they're happy
with the way that Browns devolved and
for them going into next year that like
look we want to make changes that goal
is to make playoffs to the LEC so if
they can shape up and achieve that then
they'll be happy
well talking of Excel obviously you know
one thing that we always look forward to
is the world's song what did you think
of excels boasters effort what did you
think of that because everyone's kind of
waiting for the announcement cuz it's
such a big thing and then boaster was
like don't worry about ah I've got this
Cup it was definitely a song I'll say
that much you know I I respect the
effort let's take a look at it now if
you are I haven't seen it let's take a
look at collapse of craps you don't know
what you're gonna see came to dominate
living the group of death but that
doesn't really matter me my boy reckless
eating your for breakfast who is a word
of advice don't underestimate splines
up next is CK keeping all the other
major heart attack within you got
Griffin and damn
[Music]
like weird mix of genres it's kind of
like rap but then also the ukulele
[Applause]
well Dan one of the most exciting things
that you have been up to is you know you
already know I can see that smile on
your face you got invited to riots
10-year anniversary event how was that
what are the things that you got up to
that I was amazing what are the bragging
rights so many big names from currently
within legal legends but also people
have been interest involved in the scene
before and then it was just the event as
a whole we got there we got a loop box
full of goodies and then we're invited
to it was at the Exile side of the same
place - ejects was and they had a ton of
PC set up we got to play their new car
game legends runeterra you could play
some League of Legends I even got a
chance to play their new mobile port off
League of Legends well rip and we were
there for the European announcement of
all these new games it was just such a
hype environment to be in the speaking
of they'll see the mobile port here how
do you think that's gonna kind of open
you know the game up some maybe new
markets that hadn't hadn't been playing
the game before yeah I think a big thing
is it's not just a mobile port they've
actually remade the game and move our
fashion because they felt like if they
just translate everything over it
wouldn't fit as well from mobile
audience obviously they had to have
mobile controls but to change things
like make the game shorter pays less
minions - away faster goal generation
and the games you know you sort of have
like a 20 minute game time compared to
League of Legends which is usually quite
a bit longer than mass so even if you're
not so much a big mobile player if
you're looking for a sort of a quicker
game if you'll have as much time I think
it's definitely you can have a go on I
think it's fascinating to see so many
games kind of coming out with mobile
versions at the moment of see pub G
we've seen Call of Duty recently and now
we're seeing your league legend I think
it real it's a real market that in the
next few years you have to wonder kind
of where it's going to end up well I
think that they had TFT
they've also announced legend - antara
both those games they have planned on
release to be available on mobile and on
your desktop amazing walks thank you so
much obviously for for having a chat
with us but I think it's about time you
know if it's right with you to introduce
the man who sat
far safer he's been very quiet over
there to be waiting his turn is of
course a Gregan let's take a look at
what gets up to
[Music]
Chauncey's oddity
[Applause]
vitality spoiling these guys for the
team and to have so many people back in
us as last bit amazing obviously we
should talk to you first you've got that
vitality shirt on your support in the
black and yellow our RCS Stevens says
season seven champions ladies and
gentleman we give our players it's one
of the most unbelievable feelings ever
just as three main things I described it
is the overwhelming joy of winning
I couldn't smile hard enough I wanted to
smile like you know the whole like
speechless thing would you talk about
you like are they're just saying that
genuinely was speechless didn't know
what to say and then the the fatigue of
going through a whole tournament the
fact that this is a two-year project to
try and become world champion it's all
built up to that moment that was pretty
special and then just not knowing what
to do next normally I'm like what's the
next game and then suddenly like there
is no more games
or what do we do now and the trophy it
was incredible
well obviously season seven went
fantastically for you but we're now
moving into season eight how is that
looking Season eight is kind of crazy
rocket League eSports it's kind of crazy
at the moment the last eight events we
haven't had a single double winner
they've all been different winners and
we're going into one of the most chaotic
are LCS seasons yet in both North
America and Europe no one knows what any
games gonna turn out to be there's only
one team that's remained consistent in
North America there's the big three who
normally finish first second third two
of those are now in the middle of the
pack one of them is fighting out of
relegation potentially and then in
Europe it's just anyone can win it's
crazy I mean what do you attribute you
that to at the moment how close those
teams are and you know how competitive
this season seems to be is there any
particular reason you could put your
finger on I think it's just there's such
a huge pool of talent now because raqqa
League is a very new concept in terms of
eSports you can't have transit you can't
transition of FPS shooter into rocket
League because the skills are so
different so now we're seeing a huge
amount of players you've got that skill
set
there's just shuffling going on players
who are staying around maybe a bit too
long
new players coming in for example in
North America Pittsburgh Knights are
doing really well and they came up
through the lower league and they've
come in and started beating everyone
because they've got that drive they've
got that passion they're new to the
league
do you feel confident that you know your
team will be able to do just as well in
this coming season with all this new
talon with all this you know none of the
teams constantly winning the same thing
that lack of consistency you feel
confident you can recreate those results
I'll tell you now I've never felt
confident because I see the highs and
lows of the team you obviously have to
try and go in with the intention of
doing your best but for example in day 2
of worlds that we won
I was moping in my hotel room thinking
are we done enough when you do more
because you always can see what you can
do better but then obviously we did have
enough on that occasion and every game I
have no idea how it's going to go we
just try and prepare as much as possible
and play the best we can I believe in
the team as long as they play their best
we are probably the best team on paper
at any game but then every team is now
raising their their level so we just
have to keep being more and more
consistent that's tough let's talk about
vitality as an organization because
obviously you know you're hugely
involved with rocket League yourself but
you have other responsibilities as well
when we saw AGX you had a couple of
street fighter players that were there
while you were kind of hanging around
what's my talent you like it or as an
organization at the moment it's amazing
organization to be a part of with
growing and developing incredibly fast
huge levels of investment and I think
the future is very bright for us in
terms of getting teams that are winning
a lot more tournaments you know coming
at the top for example our csgo team
it's done fantastic this year the rocket
League team done well and we just want
to be the strongest team possible the
hard-working team and I've always got to
mention if I told you that some of the
best content in eSports we have
incredible brand team and the the amount
of production we put on is fantastic and
I'm sure you're gonna be seeing some
good stuff coming up soon well Greg
thank you so much it sounds like you
have had obviously an amazing season
seven and hopefully an amazing season
eight but all this talk about rocket
League has really made me want to watch
the other final episode challenge from
this season where we find out the final
winner isn't gonna be team mark it's
gonna be team well Rachel but geo let's
find out
hi ladies and gentlemen it is time for
the final rocket League challenge of
this series we've got Jackie joining
myself my brother this is gonna be an
easy win we've got GM we've got orcs
going up against this they've drawn
drafting in Greg in as well
you know rocket League coach
extraordinaire it's a little bit unfair
but we've also decided if I win back use
me Oh mark how is this like some sim see
wait wait what is this defense so I use
the spike get them in a full Hedgehog
bang good is that Kentucky we are about
to steal the win Jackie Jackie on the
oh and then the last one
don't don't game me like I'm loving this
Rachel
Gigi's you seem Rachel in three sweet
victory I mean obviously many things the
phone we had a code right
dan knows what he's doing need any new
players you went in pretty confident you
would turn out your victory laps you
were going to run around the studio how
did those go
did you see the highlights like some of
those saves is just ridiculous and like
let's take ourselves back because I was
thinking right if we're gonna be fair
about this two weeks there was a rocket
league player basically stumpy
somebody's got a lot of hours and then
you get a rocket League coach you take
those two out of the equation you make
this fair I win 2-1 this series that's
how I sit I held out my hand to shake
yours afterwards it took you about three
minutes before you'd actually shake my
hand I'm sore loser sportsmanship I try
my best anyway
let's leave rocket League in the past
where it should because I didn't win
unless they can look ahead let's look at
the month ahead
coming up this month the WCS Global
Finals sees out the Starcraft 2 year
live from Blizzcon October 25th to
November 2nd the group stages have come
to a close and with three LEC teams
making it to playoffs well to 2019 is
shaping up to be huge for the European
League one of the more visually stunning
csgo events of the year returns to
Copenhagen for two days of CS action for
the better part of November the pub G
Global Finals will see 32 teams strive
to bring home the chicken dinner
November 9th and 10th Japan will host
one of the biggest non major events in
the Rainbow six calendar is certainly
not want to miss our first dota major
past ti9 sees us visit the panda capital
of the world to start off the 2020 DPC
circuit
ok ladies and gentlemen it is time to
announce our competition winner neo up
be wondering what this is of course
we've got the cake we ramp it up every
single time here on the omen eSports
report gee I don't know how to celebrate
how's this sound wait wait let's find
out who our winner is please give us the
winner let's get the competition winner
ladies and gentlemen the winner of this
week's competition is Ricky Hamlin
congratulations gonna do it for this
season look just this show for this
season thank you so much to our
wonderful guests for joining us so much
for filling in it has been a lot of fun
this season a huge thank you to every
single person who's tuned in is what
she's got involved it's been a pleasure
to keep you update with everything in
eSports but for now unfortunately that's
gonna do it all thank you all so much
for watching we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
myself and all the three guests it
[Music]
[Music]
you